there are five statewide ballot
questions on your ballot this year these
would make changes to nevada's
constitution
today we're going to tackle question
three it had to pass through the
legislative sessions
twice in 2017 and again in 2019 to get
on the ballot question three deals with
the state pardons board and the power it
has so first
what does the pardons board do it does
not erase a conviction but it will
restore certain rights to a pardon felon
such as serving on a jury and gun
ownership right now the pardons board is
made up of the governor
the attorney general and the supreme
court justices
added to the state constitution require
the board to meet
quarterly allow anyone on the board to
bring up items for discussion
right now just the governor can do that
removes a requirement for the governor
to vote yes
for a pardon to be granted that had
effectively served as a veto
the argument for is the board will meet
more frequently and timely
and a pardon would not just be on the
whims of the governor
the argument against is that the board
would meet even if there are not
qualified applicants and questioning why
we would take away the veto power of the
governor
when they have it over bills from the
legislature
now if question three is approved it
would be part of the state's
constitution on november 24th
we'll tell you about ballot questions
four and six
coming up at 6 30. and if you still have
some questions about how to vote we've
got you covered all you have to do is
head to
election 101 section right there on our
home page at eightnewsnow.com
and there you will find everything you
need to know